hey what's up on today's show we got a
hard show ahead of us we got a boyfriend
who's non-committal after four or five
years we got
boundary setting with a brother-in-law
was getting out of prison we talked to
our new friend park
an asian who's studying here in the
united states and the disgusting racism
that he's facing
stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what up what up this is john with
the dr john daloni show hope you're
doing well
hope you're staying out of trouble hope
your friends are getting along well i
hope you and your family
are doing all right and if you're stuck
somewhere by yourself i hope you're
reaching out to folks hope you're doing
okay hope you're laughing
hey if you haven't watched the new nate
barghotzi special on netflix it's
awesome it's hilarious
i hope you're finding ways to laugh
right this isn't really a commercial for
nate but
man i'm so glad you're here give us a
shout if you want to be on the show we
talk about relationships mental health
stuff
marriages breaking up get all of it man
everything
one eight four four six nine three
thirty two ninety one that's one
eight four four six nine three thirty
two ninety one
we have two things of business here um
one for the podcast team and one for the
youtube crew
so i was just getting ready to go with
the show here and so here's the thing
i work at ramsey solutions here in
nashville
and this building is full of like a
thousand of the most creative people
on earth there's people from disney and
pixar all
the places you can imagine there are
creative folks
they migrate and work here even james
and kelly work here
um they were here before things got
really creative but they're still here
right
so we're about to shoot the show and
then
my man matt hudson comes in the
the creative extraordinaire
and he brought me these and if you can't
see it
these are can you can you show matt in
there in the booth
zach look at that guy wave
dude he made me a bunch of stickers that
are rocket ships
being fueled by diarrhea rocket diarrhea
stickers if you will
do what can you it's the most absurd
awesome sticker i've already put it on
my water bottle here
this is why you work with creative
people because they will make rocket
diarrhea stickers listen
um the first person to dm me after this
episode
airs and just say i want a sticker i'm
going to mail you some
way to use your creative talents to
bring joy to my life man
i'm gonna put these all over my kids
lunch boxes i'm gonna
i'm gonna put them all over my wife's
car i'm for sure gonna put them on
kelly's car
this is so great you've made my whole
week man thanks brother for using your
creative talents for
good you could have been using them for
evil to make stickers that say like
my kid's an honors student are stupid
stuff like that but nope
you took the show colors and made
rockets being fueled by diarrhea dude
i'm sucks i'm so happy
that makes that makes me laugh it makes
me joyful all right and
here's the other thing um so
the guy who serves is kind of the vp of
delony right the guy who's like the
manager who runs my life here
um he lives in a neighborhood and last
this past weekend
nashville just got smoked with with rain
i think we got seven inches six half
inch like that in one night
it was wild and um there was flooding
all throughout the city
um just a lot of damage a lot of people
struggling a lot of people rallying
together
and then this there's like a
neighborhood um
facebook page in his neighborhood his
name is cody in his in cody's
neighborhood
and somebody's house flooded and they
had standing water all through the house
and so they ran the sub-pump all night
to get all the water out
and there's probably a sub-pump that was
borrowed by another neighbor or somebody
dropped it off everybody's helping each
other out
and then somebody dresses up so they can
they disguise themselves
and so they're not they're not seen on
like the little ring cameras
and they go up to the door and they
leave this note and it's a picture of a
note here
i'm going to read it to you here's what
the note says
your sub pump dear so-and-so your
sub-pump
kept our entire family up for the entire
night
it clicked off about 4 30 a.m likely
because there was no more water in your
house or yard
it's so loud it shakes our house how can
you think that's the neighborly thing to
do
want water out of your backyard that's
fine do it at a reasonable hour
there are quiet hours in this
neighborhood next time the cops will be
called no questions asked
so since this is my show i just wanted
to say
if you wrote this you're not a very good
person
and i want you to know that people like
this exist out in the world
and they get swallowed up by the people
who show up and were
cleaning houses for neighbors they were
showing up and loaning equipment they
were
some guy came and was helping me my
driveway got completely washed out and
he shows up with his tractor and starts
helping the driveway
my son and i were pulling sticks out of
the road and logs out of the road
everybody in this company is helping
folks who were
had stuff um had their houses
covered up in water man people getting
reaching out to each other i want you to
know that there are idiots
in morons and just genuinely bad people
in the world
and uh but i want you to know this
there's more good than bad
there's more good people out there
helping and serving than this type of
person
and i want you to know if you receive a
note like this or somebody pipes into
your social media
outlet or your whatever your stupid
little digital box
on the facebooks or the internets
whatever and they leave you stupid notes
or evil notes or me notes
i want you to know that um they're not
the only voice out there
and somebody who's gonna leave this kind
of notes got a lot of demons in their
own heart and their own soul and their
own family
and um i'm gonna think positive thoughts
about them because i'm not gonna wear
this stuff
and i want you to know that there's more
good than ugly
in the world period end of story
um and as this person writes here
to the neighbor who disguised himself
and left this letter on my sister's
doorstep
your lack of compassion and
self-awareness have not go unnoticed
i'm certain it wasn't the torrential
downpour the thunder or 2000 plus
lightning strikes
is what have kept you up i pray as you
watch the news today on this palm sunday
your heart softens as your fellow
neighbors
help each other out happy sunday all i
concur
oh man that makes me think we all need
another rocket diarrhea sticker right
there man can you imagine james can you
imagine
you're not even a good person and you
wouldn't put a note like that out there
good
god almighty now i'm feeling really
guilty for writing the thing
you should and what's super funny is you
didn't even you weren't trying to
disguise yourself
that's just how you look black that's
how you showed up all right let's go
uh to jamie in indianapolis jamie what's
going on
how are we doing i'm doing well how are
you i'm good i'm good
i've got my stickers i've got my bad
attitude out of the way and now we are
ready to to
help some people in europe what's going
on well first of all i'm super jealous
of your stickers
but um and i'm super grateful to be
talking to you thanks for taking my call
listen
jamie you should be super jealous of
these stickers if you can see them
they're incredible
but such such it is all right so what's
up
um so my boyfriend and i have been
together for almost five years now it'll
be five years next month
and why that's so long
um well we're basically married without
being married
um and this is probably my own fault but
i really i thought that this would
really be the year that he proposed that
he would propose and it sounds like
that's
not happening anytime soon and what made
you what made you think that
that this was the year um this is i tend
to read into things way too much
so that's enough like i said my own
fault and i own that but
um i at work every year he's gotta
um pick vacations right at the beginning
of the year
and he happened to have off valentine's
day and my birthday and our anniversary
and i thought for sure it would happen
at one of those times
and so he didn't say anything you just
looked at the calendar and you're like
one of these is
is gonna be it yeah which
yeah it's i shouldn't have let myself
think like that i don't i don't know if
that's
necessarily the case i mean i i'm as
hopeful and optimistic and
and reading into things as the next
person why do you want to marry this guy
he's he's a good person and we make such
a good team like we just
we've knocked out debt together which i
know is
definitely not what you guys teach but
um i mean we just we just make such a
good team we
we build each other up we we've helped
each other grow so much
we we love each other like crazy i mean
why does
why doesn't he want to marry you
i wish i knew and i think that's what
i'm having
so much trouble dealing with so in one
hand you've told me
all these things you do together you
make such a great team
you complement each other you're renee
zellweger and he's tom cruise like
you complete him and it all comes
together except you can't have this one
conversation about why you're not
married
i've tried to bring up the conversation
um
and it upsets him when i bring it up and
he what do you mean it upsets him you
said that like
a young child and it's like we must keep
the floors clean before daddy comes home
because it upsets him like that's what
like what do you mean it upsets him
um
it's it's kind of hard to describe it's
almost like a
it's almost like a trauma response it's
he just he feels
really angry and almost a little bit
attacked and
i i don't it's kind of hard to describe
i'm sorry so no that's okay so
are in lieu of him feeling attacked for
you saying hey we've been doing this for
four or five years you know my heart you
know where i want to be you know that we
are great together
you instead of him feeling one
quote-unquote attack you
like um you endure
small attack after attack after attack
every single day upon
week upon month upon year why is
his feelings and
um emotional state so much more
important than yours
i guess that's a good question because
you're hurting right
it does hurt yeah and i mean i'm trying
to hey hold on no
no it's okay to hurt yeah this sucks and
people can say whatever they want
blah blah blah about well you you
shouldn't have man i would have done the
same thing
i would have looked at the dates and
like ooh one of these is going to be it
i would have done the same thing you
know what i mean
um you're not dumb or bad or anything
like that you're heartbroken and that's
okay
i'm never going to take that away from
somebody the real question is like what
can i do to help what do you want to do
i guess i just need help knowing how to
be patient
with him because that's that's basically
what he just asked me for was patience
what's he waiting for
i mean he's i think he's still just kind
of scared by the idea
of being married we i mean a lot of
marriages and his family aren't good
we just watched my parents go through a
really bitter divorce
um do you all live together
we do yes and you've joined finances to
get i mean what does he think is going
to be different
is he just leaving the door cracked a
little bit in case he just needs to run
out
or is not getting married like his his
little blankie that keeps him warm and
safe at night
i'm not sure i mean that probably could
be a good way to put it honestly um
i mean when i've asked him about it
before i mean he says stuff about
divorce statistics and
um the living with statistics are just
as bad if not worse
oh yeah i've i've brought that up see so
it's not a data conversation
um so i'll tell you here here's my
personal story
me and my wife dated for five years we
broke up a whole bunch and dated people
off and on in between
and all that um and it was ultimately a
conversation i had
fishing with my buddy ryan and he
looked at me as only guys can do at
midnight after you know there's
you stop like pretending and we're just
sitting out there
with our stupid catfish lines in the
water and there's nothing doing
and he said why aren't you married and i
said bro
no man i'm just like being single and he
said dude you no you don't you don't do
anything single people do you're boring
you don't go out you don't date or like
what are you doing
and i remember thinking i don't know
what am i doing
and he's like that's the person you're
supposed to marry what do you
and it was that i had to have somebody
just talk to me right
otherwise i was just peeting around and
being a
wimpy child brat is what i was being
and we weren't even living together i
mean we were we were just dating dating
here's the thing you've already accepted
this as is
and so for him another year can be
another two years can be another three
years it could be another five years
another 10 years because what's
why why change what he's got right now
he's got a great roommate he's got
somebody who
he loves he's got somebody who's on the
same page with him financially he's got
someone who's on the same page with him
everything except doesn't want to be
commit to stability
so why change it for him
there's no that's a really good point
there's nothing in his world that needs
changing
at all and if the person he says he
loves
wants to change then all he has to do is
throw a temper tantrum about it get his
feelings hurt and then you'll back so
far off
and you won't bring it up again for a
year you'll hurt over it you'll ache
over it
you'll dream about it you'll check his
calendar about it
but you won't wade into that
uncomfortable water
and then then you're out and so there's
no reason for him to change it so i'll
ask you
what do you want to change
i mean i would i i would like us to be
married i just love the idea
of
everybody that matters to us being in
the room together and holding us
accountable
to those vows we would make to each
other i love that too i'm an old i dude
i'm self-admitted i'm an old-fashioned
marriage nerd when it comes down to it
i'm still a sucker for it i love it
and um so yeah i'm i'm with you on that
but at the end of the day you gotta ask
yourself are you gonna walk out the door
are you gonna hang on so five years
later
are you still in the same boat or is
there a or
what moment for you or an if then moment
for you have you put a date on the
calendar
i haven't i'm i'm very type a
and i've considered it but i've
type a is usually a defense mechanism
and
yeah what's in your heart
if he says hey i'm not i'm not getting
married to you like
i love you you're my person but i'm not
gonna do it he's gonna
he's gonna call it what it is and just
be together for the next 10 years
or are you gonna say i want someone
who's going to respect me
and the life that i want to live and i'm
out
yeah i guess that's kind of why i'm at
an impasse because he keeps saying it is
going to happen
but there is zero
no none zero impetus for him to change
anything
none i'm not even blaming him there's
nothing there's no reason for him to
disrupt his life
none
my concern for you is what happens when
he does marry you then the kid question
comes up the whose parents are we going
to stay at over thanksgiving comes up
the
the hey we're going to go to my parents
for christmas and we're going to go to
his parents for
these hard conversations will emerge
time and time again they're just going
to get
way way more complex and harder right
are we going to send our kids to this
school or that school are we going to
move to this because i got this new job
and my bigger concern for you guys is
not that you were together for five
years
i did this and i've got a better
marriage than most the folks i know
it's hard all marriage is hard all
relationships are hard they're a mess
they're
a challenge so the time isn't that big a
deal
my concern is you all don't have a
platform to have hard conversations
together
or deep meaningful this really
matters to me conversations because it
sounds like when you
lay that on the table he turtles up says
you don't care about me
this really hurts and it's everyone's
and then you back way off because you
want peace
is that fair yes and that's totally fair
and i am trying to work on that i've
been reading gottman and chapman and
trying to
hear kindness hey listen i thought more
about these things
you don't have to read anything else all
you have to do is remember this
your what you want really really matters
and often 21st century women are
conditioned
to be peacekeepers your job is to make
sure everybody else is okay
and i want you to know that's not your
job in this relationship you are a
fierce um co-member of this relationship
you're 50 of it and you should be a
hundred percent of it for him
and he should be 100 of it for you and i
know that math doesn't work and i don't
care relational math never works
you all should be in this all together
and you should at least be able to sit
down and have this conversation where he
can explain to you without getting his
feelings hurt without being
drama without throwing a temper tantrum
it's coming it's gonna be
without all that nonsense he should be
able to sit down and say
here's what really scares the crap out
of me about this
and his feelings could be really valid
on that i just hate growing up temper
tantrums
and vice versa you should be able to to
articulate here's why i want to
solidify this etch it into concrete and
stone so that we are right or die till
the end of time
because right now like we i just want to
have a party so everybody holds us
accountable that's not a good reason
either
like why do you want to
take what you guys have and elevate it
to marital status
forever right why are you going to bind
yourself this guy you all need to be
able to have that hard conversation
because it just
gets harder and harder and harder and i
tell you what
there are some girlfriends in my past
that i would do anything to go back and
redo conversations because i acted like
an idiot i was a child i was a [ __ ] i
hurt people's feelings not because i was
trying to be rude or
i just didn't know how to do it and then
i would do anything to be able to go
back and have some conversations
early in my marriage with my wife
because i didn't know what i was doing
and i threw temper tantrums
not in a slamming door kind of way but
in the kind of way you're describing the
you know what i mean just that dramatic
and
so here's the thing i want you to have
the courage
to have your voice be heard you deserve
to have your voice be heard in this
thing
what you want what you deserve what you
envision in this thing it matters it's
important jamie
and it counts it counts
and if you are already if you've already
over four and five years created a world
where
all he has to do is throw a temper
tantrum and he gets what he wants
all he has to do is um
say i don't want to talk about it and
you're like cool cool cool cool cool
man you deserve more than that jamie
and i'll tell you your if if your fiance
husband
i mean your boyfriend whatever when your
boyfriend hears this
you deserve to have to articulate what's
going on in your heart man
not just play some kind of angry it's
gonna happen someday
sit down and have grown-up conversations
and if y'all can't do this go see a
counselor
right now a relationship counselor
together that helps you map this stuff
out together
okay you both deserve to live in a
relationship where both of you are fully
heard fully expressed and fully happy
and those are not all mutually exclusive
not everybody wins right
but listen if you win
and he loses you both lose and if he
wins and you win
everybody wins and there's a ways to do
that by communicating
listen jamie i know this is hard to know
this is heartbreaking i'm not gonna take
that from you i already said that i'm
not gonna take it from you
i hate this for you i want this to be
the moment you say you know what my
voice
it matters here it matters in this
relationship
it does and if you don't have somebody
in your life that thinks your voice
matters or that theirs matters more than
you
i want you to think hard about meeting
with somebody about is this the
relationship for the rest of your life
because it just gets harder from here
thank you so so much for the call let's
go to tracy in st
louis what's up tracy uh
you know just living the dream good for
you i'm glad somebody is that's awesome
how are you what can i do to help how
are you um
no it's actually funny because i had a
pretty bad day before this but
my question is how do
my husband and i tell his parents my
in-laws that
we're not going to have anything to do
with my brother-in-law who is soon to be
released from prison
without it sounding like i don't like a
declaration of war you know like
you know like you have to pick a side
i don't know i don't know that you can
it sounds like you've
declared war and you've picked a side
well
no we don't want them to feel like they
have to pick a side
but we want to make it clear that like
we're not going to have anything to do
with him and so like he's not invited to
our house
we won't be attending gatherings that
he's at but we're happy to be
you know flexible if they're gonna do
things together you
you know we're not gonna say well
christmas dinner is at our house at noon
be there or don't um what did this guy
do
um that's irredeemable
so he's in prison
for committing burglaries okay
um but leading up to that
he had stolen over fifty thousand
dollars from
my in-laws that's their issue yeah our
our
issue is that while he's been in prison
he has spent
hundreds of letters to
my in-laws house where we used to live
talking about
all kinds of crazy and violent things
including fratricide
and he also thinks that my nine-year-old
step-daughter
my husband's daughter is his spirit
child and
he is spiritually her father whoa
and and that combined with the violent
letters makes
so we're not willing to risk
her or my husband yeah so are
your in-laws planning on welcoming them
back with open arms or are they going to
get a restraining order the moment he
gets out of jail
i i don't i mean my mother-in-law just
tried to buy a house
for him that didn't pass the home plan
so he's not actually going to be really
he's scheduled to be released this
coming
saturday yeah but because it didn't pass
the home plan
he's not coming but now we're like okay
we need to have this conversation
because i mean the main issue is really
my stepdaughter
because i'll die before i let him
near her so let's step back from him
because this is supercharged
okay this is really heavy let's back it
up and just say that your in-laws
asked you to go camping in the arizona
desert in august
as a family and they said hey this is
our jam this is what we do
you just married into this family little
lady we all go
camping in arizona in august it's hot
hot and we get sunburned it's kind of a
family tradition
in fact we put little stickers on our
bodies
and we get sunburned all around them
we're just weirdos right
and you family did that that's not weird
just for the record tracy it's super
weird but
it's not it's not weird at all um but
you didn't know about this you married
him and then all of a sudden
one night uh y'all are laying in your
bed and the lights are off and you just
say
hey honey and he's like yeah babe and
you say there's no chance i'm going
camping in arizona none
zero and he starts laughing he's like i
was waiting for you to say that i get
that
and then you have to have that
conversation with his in-laws and it's
just as simple as
hey we love you guys we're not gonna go
camping this year
um but we can't wait to see at the
holidays
and the more you try to explain
dramatize give
reasons examples on the back end the
more complicated and messy it gets
and so that's not a charge situation it
could become one depending on how cool
or lame your in-laws are but it is what
it is
when it comes to this this is somebody
who's demonstrated to you in your eyes
that
they're not safe that they don't intend
on being safe
they haven't been safe in the past
they're not going to be safe in the
future
and so it's just a very simple
we will not be communicating with this
person in any shape form or fashion in
any way
and we may even pursue a restraining
order when they get out of jail
we don't want them near us near our um
daughter
and then we're going to go happily about
our lives if you choose to have in their
life
great we will not be there and there
just appeared at the end of that
sentence said in a matter-of-fact way
not a good war way not an angry way but
just a way that this is
what's gonna happen as though the sky is
blue and our grass is somewhat green
and any sort of drama on the back end is
not yours you cannot
be responsible for how other people
experience your boundaries
you know what i mean yeah it's just
it's it sucks it's not your it's not you
didn't close it but now it's in your lap
and you've got to deal with it right
right like somebody ring your door
really close tonight i guess i worry
that like this was definitely
going to be a barrier to that if your
in-laws choose for it to be
it will be that doesn't mean you're not
doing the right thing
it doesn't mean that it doesn't change
over time it doesn't mean that four
years later three years from now two
years from now this guy's
out and he's cool and he's doing his
work and doing his thing and
taking his med whatever he's got to be
doing and y'all make some concessions
and changes
um but if y'all don't feel safe if you
don't feel comfortable
this is an easy easy situation an easy
boundary to draw
this isn't like hey i don't like
sleeping outside this isn't like i don't
want to drive halfway across the country
i guess it's a simple boundary to draw
it's not an easy boundary to draw
because like it's just like you know
like it's
simple like it's straightforward and i
get that i guess i was you know
spoken like oh he's really good at stuff
maybe he'll have something to say that
won't upset people and they'll just be
like oh yeah i totally get your
viewpoint
there is when it comes to somebody who
has
lost perspective with one of their kids
there is no
rational conversation you can have
straightforward
as short as possible and then you
separate
that's it so whenever you're bringing
somebody in to let them go
to fire them from their job that should
be a
very very short conversation and we're
going to let you go
in a week or two um we'll circle back
and you can meet with hr to get the
specifics um that we've chosen at this
time to let you go
if would you ever let me
if you've got well it's it's the kindest
think about it ripping a band-aid off or
a surgeon
right do you want the surgeon to take
the blunt instrument
and just drag it across your poor little
leg no
you want to use the sharpest item
they've got the smallest
most precise tool and they want to make
a quick cut a concise cut and get it
done
right same thing here um
it cannot be a surprise to your in-laws
it can't be
unless they've just become delusional
too and that does happen
right when you're i met parents like
that
with students of mine that were that way
but we had to come to jesus talk two
christmases ago
okay because i say it's my in-laws but
it's my mother-in-law okay
you know my father-in-law if you take
him aside he is
totally against it but then he needs to
stand up too for the safety of his
family
and he's choosing not to so he's
choosing not to protect his family
yeah and you know my husband has two
other brothers and
vocally they're you know also like no he
can't be
back into our lives unless he's willing
to
go through all of the hoop of probation
and parole and you know get on
medication and get help because clearly
what's in those letters like you cannot
be a sound mind yeah so
and i am so happy you're super lucky
here so join forces together
do that meeting together make sure
everybody's on the same page
maybe even write a letter and if you
want to be really straightforward and
bold send him a letter in jail
that because of your behavior because of
your letters you're not going to be
welcome
at our home until you do the following x
y and z let him know up front so we can
hold this letter we love you we wish the
best for you
we can't help you at this time and the
the things that you're writing in these
letters are making us uncomfortable for
the protection of our family
you don't have to do that um you can
you can write that letter to your mom or
your mother-in-law knowing that she's
probably gonna show it to him right
but here's the thing there is no
shortcut to a hard conversation
say it be clear concise know exactly
what you want to say and then get out
and bail
right it's as straightforward as humanly
possible
and there is no easy way to do it
there's no way that it doesn't
um isn't uncomfortable the quicker and
cleaner that cut the
quicker and cleaner it can heal right i
just
never even thought of that surgery
analogy until just now and i think it
works pretty good
all right let's take one more call think
tracy thank you for that call it sucks
i do want to know how the conversation
goes though if you will have that
conversation with your in-laws
draw that line you're going to feel
weight leave your shoulders we've done
it this is it
you are not going to feel good when he
gets out of jail you're not
unless you get some sort of police
protection or some sort of come to jesus
conversation maybe between your husband
and him
in the jail before you leave some sort
of closure conversation but
chances are this is gonna be something
that's gonna haunt your family for the
future and you all have to be really
clear on your boundaries and really
direct
all right let's talk to uh park in
indianapolis
indiana what's up park how we doing
brother
i'm doing great how are you man i could
not be doing much better
it is beautiful out today and i'm doing
all right so what's going on man how can
i help
um so first of all i'm asian
yes and i'm getting attacked frequently
because of my race
oh my gosh hey hold on man hold on hold
on
okay dude i'm sorry
ah yeah man i'm heartbroken for you tell
me about what's going on
so um last week i was at the parking lot
at the front of the grocery store
and there was a man who called me like
chinese virus
and he said go back to comedy to china
you don't deserve to be here
so he even kicked my shopping cart
i'm not exaggerating he kicked my
shopping cart and
i had to pick up all the stuffs from the
ground
so do you miss that i'm healthy
no no one helped me
no one helped me so i was so scared yeah
i felt so lonely
yeah and then so
i'm so scared of going out and buying
groceries going to class
i feel like i might get killed because
of my race
you know yeah dude i'm so sparked man
hey
i'm so so sorry how old are you man uh
23
23 what are you studying yeah uh i'm
studying economics in college
yeah um what school what school are you
at
my school yeah um
uh you know you don't tell me that you
don't tell me that's cool um okay
so tell me about tell me about who you
are tell me about your story
okay so first of all i'm from south
korea
yeah and i moved to the united states
after i finished my elementary school
from south korea because of my
parents job yeah so i first moved to
boston
and i attended the middle school there
and after that
after finishing middle school i had
to decide whether i go back to south
korea for high school
or stay in the united states and then
i decided to stay in the united states
and then i attended high school and at
that time i
stayed at the homestay
and after that i finished my high school
and then
i got accepted to the college in indiana
and i and i moved to indiana and
right now i'm staying in apartments
going to school studying economics and
also
i'm doing a remote internship at one of
the software like it software company
in silicon valley so awesome hey
good for you dude listen i
hate this it's disgusting
and it's evil and
that crap should not be going on man
absolutely listen to me um
it shouldn't be going on and i'm sorry
that you can't go outside and you feel
scared to go to the grocery
store because somebody attacked you
already it's nonsense and it's
ridiculous
and i'm heartbroken for you
i'm heartbroken for the idiots who think
that's a good idea
and it makes me feel better i'm
heartbroken for you i'm heartbroken for
the
pastor buys who didn't stop and
intervene
and even those who were terrified who
didn't stop and help you pick up your
stuff i'm heartbroken by the whole mess
dude
you deserve better than this from from
the citizens of indianapolis and you
deserve better than this from the cities
citizens of your community and park i'm
sorry
thank you for yeah i know that doesn't
make you any safer at the grocery store
brother but i'm sorry i should not
tell me about your community there do
you have a group of people that you love
and interact with are you stuck all by
yourself
people isolating you tell me what's
what's going on in your community there
so you know since last year
i have been staying by myself because
majority of my friends are
international students like mostly from
china
taiwan sure and some of them are from
like vietnam
and since kobe 19 hit the united states
very hard
majority of them went back to their
country
and i also tried to get a flight ticket
but it was so expensive
and also you know in south korea if i
entered there i had to do self
quarantine for two weeks
right and i have to pay for it and also
due to time zone difference like
it is so difficult for me to take class
during the midnight
like two or three a.m in the morning in
south korea so it's nonsense for me so
i just decided to stay in the united
states and
since covet i have not
meeting my friend face to face only like
chatting
like facebook chat and that's it oh man
so listen you you you may have heard me
on the show before
understanding the physiology of that you
realize that your body is
slowly folding in on itself from
loneliness right
right um and you're in a tough tough
situation because
you have to be in proximity to other
people you have to
you got to you've got to have a
community people that you can interact
with
talk to communicate with that will help
that your brain
feel safe and at the same time you're in
a situation now where you can't even go
to the grocery
store man i hate that
um tell me about your school
when i was the student affairs
guy at multiple universities
we worked with students in your
situation to make sure they were safe to
provide them with some sort of community
to make sure they could
get to and from places if they needed to
there should be some support networks
built into the university are attending
is that available to you or no
oh that's available so actually like
before i send you the letter
i already talked to um my academic
advisor
and there is the organizations that
support international students
and i already talked to them but yeah i
feel like
um i have to share this story to
everybody
you're exactly right ignorance is the
problem for the racism ignorance is the
major cause
yeah so you you're going out to a whole
bunch of people
right to millions of people if if
um and and you have done a brave thing
by calling into the show
and you've done a brave thing by putting
a name
in a situation to this i want everybody
listening here
a guy just went to get groceries
and somebody kicked over the cart called
him a bunch of derogatory names
that's something he hasn't he's trying
to go to college
he's trying to help out you and your
communities
this type of stuff is disgusting man
so if you could say anything to the
millions of people
listening to this what would it be
i'm also belonging to your community
yeah
yes i'm asian but i'm not type of virus
i don't carry virus i already took cove
testing for two
times and they're all negative i have
been wearing musk
i have been washing my hands i have been
following the rules
but why do i have to get blamed because
i'm asian
because i'm international student
because my accent is not american
that's ridiculous amen yeah
you're right so
here's what i want every listener to
hear when you're walking
at the grocery store looking at the
prices of the fruit
looking at is there any discounts on
cereal
and you see somebody that doesn't look
like you
i want you to understand they're having
a totally different experience in that
aisle than you are
if they happen to be asian american they
happen to be asian they happen to be
visiting your community putting money
into your community and getting educated
at the schools
that you're attending to like our friend
park here
i want you know there's a chance that
they are walking down that aisle
terrified that you may reach out and
hurt them
then you may reach out and kick their
cart over and no one's gonna sit there
and
and bend down and help you pick up your
stuff
so i'm calling on every listener of this
podcast
every listener this podcast with kids
every listener this podcast who's
married or dating somebody who's got
parents
open your mouth and open your eyes
happening is ridiculous it's stupid
it's obnoxious and it's embarrassing for
our whole country
it's embarrassing we got to be better
than this park
i want to tell you on behalf of
everybody i'm glad you're here
thank you and i hope that the
ignorant ridiculous heartbreaking
actions of a few morons
will not um poison you to those of us
who love you and we're glad you're here
and i'm calling on folks of indianapolis
to step up i'm calling folks of every
city every place in the country to step
up and start serving the least of these
in our communities
especially those folks who don't look
like us because everybody's
fighting a battle inside their heart
mind
every day and we just look like we're
pushing grocery carts and we're not
life's hard the person walking in front
of you in the grocery store walking a
little bit too slow
you don't know what their marriage is
like you don't know if they got a kid in
the hospital
the young asian american guy the young
asian guy just going to get groceries
you don't know how terrified and how
tightly he's gripping that cart because
he's scared to death
park thank you so so much for your call
thanks for being brave and hey
um if somebody reaches out with a hand
of support let me know
and if any more further nonsense calls
let me know please don't hesitate to
call the police
because they're there to serve you too
please don't hesitate to call your
campus
support networks because they're there
to support you too
please call on your academic advisors
please gather allies if possible let
your classmates know what you're
experiencing
let those kids in your internship class
know what you're experiencing
and my hope is when they hear your story
that you're no longer a headline you're
no longer an issue you're no longer
something happening in somebody else's
town
hey hold on that's our buddy park
no way dude we're all going to the store
now
park you're coming with us and that's
how we combat this nonsense
park you're coming with us
all of us no more no more
man no more
oh man james um
i'm gonna wrap up the show here and i
don't
i think we're good yeah i think we're
good
i'm out no song for today guys
men and women when your neighborhood
needs you
pull out your headphones and go help
your neighbor turn this podcast off go
help your neighbor this has been the dr
john delaney show